[Music]
you
Irv do you mind starting by talking a
little bit about the early years at
Continental and specifically how similar
or different they were to a search fund
situation well okay here's the straight
story I'm gonna spend a little bit of
time on ancient history but there are
more interesting topics to talk about
today and tomorrow about today's and
tomorrow's world so I'll go through this
quickly our search was pathetic
there's no other word for it my partner
and I were both working in Boston post
MBA we had been college friends we
started comparing notes on things we
were uncovering separately then we
decided to work together and so we put
the word out through our network that we
were looking for a company that was not
too big and not too small and was
profitable that was about the only
sensible thing we said and had some
growth potential which was probably good
too and that was it for criteria so
needless to say over the first six or
eight months we looked at these
wonderful businesses like indoor tennis
centers bowling alleys residential fuel
oil companies these are literally
companies we looked at a plastic
inflatable toy company in western
Massachusetts and some other light
manufacturing business in New Jersey I
forgotten about it but after six or
eight months we did refine the criteria
a bit and we came up with the thought
that no product companies we don't want
to invest in a product company because
of product development cycles and issues
and product obsolescence so we did focus
on service companies and we also hoped
for recurring revenue which was somewhat
new thought not totally I mean a little
bit different that's certainly different
from what we had come up with and then
finally we wanted a franchise business
meaning not KFC business but a franchise
in the sense of a claim on the customer
so we did have those criteria
that we developed the next-to-last
business that we came across that we did
not start was also a comedy of errors
but we stumbled across the then nursing
home business they're all nursing homes
in the mid 60's were almost all were in
converted older houses multi-story old
houses with circular staircases and
people you know all kinds of code
violations and there the people were
stacked all around these places and so
the government passed the federal
government passed the hilbert enact say
offering long term loans at very low
cost slope slope repayment if you'd
construct new nursing home facilities
recognizing there was a huge need and we
got all excited about that because we
were both MBA types in our late 20s and
we looked at the numbers and this all
this attractive dead and this is gonna
be great so what did we do the first two
or three months we spent making up our
business plan right in the office did we
visit any nursing homes no we didn't
visit so after two or three months we
had this very elegant business plan was
really pretty nice about how we're gonna
buy it buy and builder we were not by
builder Singh other homes with this
great debt and required very little
equity and we looked at each other's and
one of us said what if we should go
visit a nursing home well we had
casually been in them visiting somebody
maybe from time to time but not really
so we visited eight or ten of them and
at the end of that process we looked at
each other and said this is not going to
be any fun at all this is actually
depressing to look at these places and
even if we run modern ones in modern
facilities this is not going to be a fun
business so to our criteria we added
either fun or at least a business that
we could engage in and feel was fair
value and was interesting to us and was
fun to kind of be around and those were
our criteria finally we stumbled across
the cable television business
and Warren Buffett has made the
statement that when good management
meets a bad industry the industry wins
well the correlative of that is also
true and was true in our case we fell
into a honeypot
of a wonderful industry and it provided
a cushion for feckless totally
inexperienced management where if
there's a mistake that could be made we
found it and that's not false modesty
it's accurate we really made a lot of
mistakes in the beginning in fact a lot
of what is caught taught here in these
courses particularly the course I'm
teaching now here is based on stuff we
did wrong just obvious we weren't we
were well educated and a halfway smart
but we just did stupid things and it's
easy to do stupid things as our
conversation will show a little later on
as it develops it serve of course is
being incredibly modest there and just
going back to something that the John
Stanton said this morning you know even
in very good industries great management
teams drive disproportionate results and
nobody else got returns like the ones I
described earlier including John
Malone's so it was being very modest
anyway level on search funds what trends
is you sort of look out there have been
most surprising or interesting for you
to observe as it relates to search funds
so what's what captures all of us really
is how much they have taken hold and a
lot of it is pretty recent they started
in the mid-80s
Kirk reading or in Jamie Turner and Jim
Southern had different versions of the
start of a search and a start of
searches and they added some
supplemental funding in one case and
both bought businesses that were
successful but in the 80s not much
happened
and then the see-through period of the
late 80s when we had a huge downturn the
see-through buildings the lattice built
that were never rented out and they
called that the see-through era not much
happened then in the 90s it picked up
some steam but then the dot-com boom
occurred in the late 90s and so that
damped everything down but then 2000
2001 came the bottom fell out of that
and that's when search funds really
picked up steam and to me I've always
thought of them just as we thought of
the cable business as just kind of an
interesting version of the real estate
business you know you build an asset you
leverage it you pay off the debt and you
own it free and clear we thought of
search funds as an opportunity for a few
interesting interested people to amass
some capital and find a good opportunity
and build a business it was a path to
entrepreneurship we had no I had no
sense that it would ever catch on the
way it has since in the in the past 15
years or so so that's certainly one
surprising thing variants are also
starting to show up institutional
capital the the purchase of secondary
shares startups from search funds longer
holding periods so recap transactions
are gradually starting to appear and
some signs of a maturing industry such
as those are appearing and and so
looking forward from today where do you
think the search fund is is headed as an
asset class looking forward say you know
5 to 10 years from today well just
backing up one second one thing I would
add to the prior and then take so what
happened to form search funds well if
you think about it you needed
opportunities you needed capital and you
needed talent opportunities have always
been there and continued to be their
capital was always waiting on the
sidelines but the Capitals position was
always will bring me a deal show me a
deal
and I'll consider investing in it so
there was not a path into the vortex if
you will and then the talent said well I
have no way to conduct a search I owe
this money from you know going to a good
MBA school and how am I going to find
I can't look for a company part-time so
the last mile was not constructed until
the search fund idea took hold and that
was really last mile construction that
brought the time to search for a company
and find a better quality company and
the attraction of the capital to have
its risk capital stepped up and then to
have a pretty low cost option on a
better quality company and that
attracted the searchers so this is kind
of I think of it as a as a last mile
bringing together of those three
critical resources so looking ahead
we're all it that this is nothing but
obvious to everybody here but the influx
of capital is bound to continue and will
probably accelerate institutional
capital is now either assembling or
appearing there will be more and more
capital opportunities are boundless
there are over a hundred thousand
companies with positive EBIT DEA of
under ten million dollars just in this
country a lot of them are not suited for
church search funds but many of them are
you could cut out product companies and
all kinds of some aren't for sale and so
on but there are a lot of them that are
and opportunities are not the problem
so capitals not the problem so what's
going to happen is that more and more
talent will be attracted and the average
quality of that talent I think will
diminish there will be people who get
funded who aren't as good as you in the
audience now and as good as the people
who have been running come from
searching for and running companies have
been this is a parallel in a sense to
the venture capital
industry were which took off in the 50s
way back in the 50s gathered some steam
in the 60s and by the 70s was an
industry but then we saw in the 80s and
90s and I'm not a student of economic
history but I do know this to be true
that then in the 80s and 90s we saw
groups of venture capital partners who
could not raise subsequent funds because
their investment record was not adequate
I think in this case we're gonna see
searchers who don't do as good a job as
as you are and those before you have
done so far the capital will flow those
people will be attracted and I think
failure rates will stop coming down very
likely I'm sad to say that but I think
it's a product of the pressures of
capital and the capital is attracted as
both practice and economic theory would
suggest when there are returns of 30
percent plus it's going to attract
capital and that's gonna have both
positive effects it's gonna have
positive effects on the best searchers
they're going to be able to drive
attractive terms at least as attractive
as those now but it's gonna have
deleterious effects on some people who
are investors and operators who are not
as competent great okay so we're gonna
shift now to a few key topics related to
managing growing companies and first you
know so Irv you have kind of a unique
perspective as a teacher and an investor
board member and a former CEO so what
are the most common mistakes you've seen
from young CEOs over the years so Jim
Harbaugh was David Shaw whom some of you
heard speak at one o'clock today the
football coach of Stanford he was David
Shaw's predecessor he came to take over
the Stanford football program in 2007
and by any measure Stanford football had
been lackluster
prior to 2007 and Jim Harbaugh's first
words to his team all of the players on
the first day of practice is were
gentlemen we're gonna win by character
and cruelty so he didn't mean cruelty he
just meant I want to move the pendulum
and get rid of this reputation for soft
play that Stanford teams had suffered
under for a number of years so I think
in response to your question I think
that it's important to plant the flag
for what kind of company you want even
if you're a first time CEO with no
experience I think I think it's okay to
say we're gonna win here here's what
matters we're gonna do it the right way
this is a meritocracy there are no
sacred cows the quality of your work
matters and the way you get along with
other people matters just set down a few
ground rules that this is a business
operation and you have the chance to
succeed and prosper I mean together with
a bunch of other messages but but make
an opening statement and just say well
at least have the people feel well he
may be young looking and inexperienced
but at least he has some ideas about
what kind of business he wants and good
for him I think a second thing a mistake
I see made often is that there's some
feeling that new CEOs have that they
have to act like a CEO and that means
put on some kind of a mask or an effect
and be someone that you're not really so
one of your direct reports comes to you
and says hey boss what do you think
about this what do you think well I'm
supposed to know the answer he or she's
asking me what I think so I blurt
something out what that's about the
dumbest I mean I
then countless times but that's dumb
that's silly you know the best answer is
I don't know let's figure this out
together
I don't know I don't know is very
powerful
it shows authenticity
it shows humility and it shows that the
desire to work with the person and help
discover what the best answer is so I
think acting like a CEO there's no such
thing act like yourself be authentic and
there are things you don't know it's ok
to admit them reflect your humaneness we
all make mistakes so admit that upfront
I don't know the answer and by the way
there's another message there Sabrosa
that's a little more subtle which is
managerial effectiveness does not
necessarily equate to knowledge of facts
or knowledge of exactly what to do
situationally but we can figure it out
together and it encourages other people
to open up and stop putting on faces as
well I think there's a couple things I'm
going to talk about later one of them is
advice seeking that's kind of come later
a little bit more is about sales but I
think it's also a mistake I see is
losing sight of the importance of all of
the people in your work force front line
middle line your key team your board
they're all people and find a way to
connect with them as much as you can
management by walking around as a
favorite phrase here was coined by Bill
Hewlett at Gillette Packard walk around
talk to somebody say hi Mary what's up
today how's your work going what are you
working on I'm Joe what are you working
on maybe you have a nametag on or maybe
they already know your job or you're
John or you're Sarah whoever you are
you're the CEO
would be gender careful here and so just
to invest a little bit of time and and
be human with the person and care about
them take an interest in them you don't
have to spend all day but walk around a
little bit get to know people I think
the last thing I would say other than
these other two categories I refer to
that we'll pick up later is it's really
important not to lose sight of what
things are really important like your
relationships with your family and your
friends and investing in yourself a bit
and what you like to do keeping yourself
healthy investing in the activities that
you like to as much as you can you
you're gonna have to sacrifice some
things under the pressure of being a CEO
and maybe it's community service for now
maybe it's some other things but be sure
it's not the things that really matter
to you the most and it's easy a lot of
CEOs who who'd get divorced blame their
companies but really they they really
oughta it's not the company's because
the world is filled with successful CEOs
who have happy family relationships and
there's no need to throw them under the
bus end of sermon sorry okay we're going
to touch next on talent management topic
we've heard some other sessions today so
any advice or thoughts on hiring
retaining and yes firing solty members
it's been said that see companies hire
behind the curve be companies hire ahead
of the curve and a companies hire and
fire ahead of the curve that's not easy
to do it sounds ruthless it's not
intended to be ruthless but if you think
about teams you have now or you have
worked with in the past there are
placeholders very likely at every strata
of the company people who are doing an
okay job now not a superior job they fit
into the culture well they probably been
there a while
people like them they have no upward
mobility as the company grows they have
no ability to do other things they don't
contribute to the thoughts of the
company those people you need to be
thinking about finding another place for
them if you can find a place inside the
company demotions don't work but as the
company grows if they can manage a
continue to manage part of what they're
doing now and do it effectively fine but
you may have to move them out of the
company and the best companies make room
for a players in key seats no b+ players
in key seats please now there are B and
C players in all great companies but
they aren't anywhere near the top of
those companies so you want to be sure
that you're hiring ahead of the curve
but also thinking about who's not
promotable who can't ride with us two
years from now we expect to have grown
40 percent who can't take that ride with
us and what changes should we be making
to make room for the right person in
those seats just mindful of the time I'm
a fan of performance management not
performance reviews so much or you have
to have performance reviews but
performance management means immediate
feedback to people I think it's it's
really useful if you talk to somebody
and say Fred the meeting we were in on
Friday
I thought your response to so-and-so was
a little tough you probably didn't
intend it that way but when so-and-so
his idea was advanced you said well that
doesn't make any sense I think we should
do such-and-such so we've got to be
really careful about the way we talk to
each other and I would ask you to be
more sensitive to how what you say lands
on other people that's a favorite phrase
of us around the stand
Business School how does your comment
land on other people it strikes me as a
little bit awkward but but we use it so
the self-awareness quotient is really
what we're talking about remember that
there are many ways of compensating your
key employees only a few of which have
to do with money in stock you can
compensate them with authentic praise
with thanks with access to information
that they might not otherwise know that
you do know by seeking their advice and
these are all legitimate ways of
connecting with key people you know
people who leave companies don't leave
companies they leave bosses be sure
you're a bust they're not going to leave
and be sure that they're gonna say boy
when I go to that next company am I
going to get the same amount of care and
praise and thanks and access to
information as I'm getting in my old
company make that a high bar for people
it's cost free and it's so effective
great and you've developed a whole
course on this earth but any overall
advice on difficult conversations and
how to best handle them so a couple of
core thoughts and difficult
conversations are one of my the ways I
think about them is directness with
respect so if you're terminating
somebody that's a difficult conversation
let's be direct with them upfront and
say it to them right in the beginning
but let's say it respectfully and pause
a pause in what you say often carries
with it respect so if I'm saying if I
say to somebody we've had a number of
meetings we've been trying to work on
this it's not working out it's really
time for you to move on and the purpose
of this conversation is to talk about
the
in the terms and conditions under which
you leave this company I'm sorry to have
to tell you this but I suspect it's not
much of a surprise and then stop just
stop and see what their reaction is
because you're showing respect and
you're showing some empathy for how they
might be feeling as opposed to talking
on and on and on and on so directness
with respect is one meeting them where
they are which is an old phrase of the
hospice movement that's one of their
mottos is meet the patient where the
patient is well meet the person you're
talking to in a difficult conversation
where she or he is so think a little bit
about where they're coming from in this
conversation there's a teacher of course
at Stanford Medical School helping
medical students play the role of
doctors in role played conversations
with patients and Families over bad
medical situations it's not dissimilar
from the Business School course except
the contexts that are obviously
different and there's one issue that I
thought of that appears in both courses
and and that is delivering bad news so
in the business school course it's a
person who expects to get a promotion
all the peers think he's going to get
the promotion
he doesn't get the promotion somebody
younger and less experienced gets the
promotion for good sufficient reason and
in the medical school there are a lot
more chips on the table it's a man 48
years old who for the past he jogs every
morning for the past week or so he's
noticed that the lower part of his right
leg and foot doesn't feel quite the same
he can't quite identify why so he goes
in the doctor doctor gives him first in
neurologist ISM tests here's the meeting
with a neurologist and the neurologist
needs to tell this 48 year old man who
was not suspecting it at all in fact he
comes into the office and says hi doctor
how's it going what's where'd you find
out from my tests very upbeat
he has MS
at the age of 48 and the students need
to be the doctor telling the patient
that he has MS so these are hard
conversations and there are all kinds of
ways of handling them I think the most
effective way is to tell the truth right
away
calmly and respectfully as opposed to a
long wind-up and a built up or some
elliptical stuff about what you may have
some neurological thing we want to do
for know what we know you have MS don't
we owe you the respect of telling you
you have MS and then we're going to
offer you a path of subsequent meetings
with physicians that can help you learn
how to mitigate it and deal with it the
best you can and the same is true in the
business school situation so I think of
meeting them where they are and
directness with respect the last thing I
would say is you know it's really easy
to write bullet points in advance of a
difficult conversation and figure out
what you're going to say but when you
start to put them in words it's not so
easy so you need to practice those
difficult conversations hopefully with a
partner or a spouse or maybe in front of
your phone and play it back or in front
of a mirror because saying the words to
somebody are very very different than
understanding the thoughts that are
written down in the bullet points on
your page practice easier and makes you
stumble less I can't tell you again not
not false modesty truth I can't tell you
how many conversations early in our
careers I bungled because I I was so
unsure of myself and didn't know what to
do and was trying to be halfway kind to
the person and I probably went on and
and on and I remember one person saying
go what are you trying to tell me anyway
well that's embarrassing
right what are you trying to tell me
we've been sitting there for five
minutes and I haven't conveyed anything
to them it's not easy
great so next up is culture yeah so what
is it and how can CEOs promulgate and
nourish it so make no mistake the
culture starts and flows from you and
it's from how you act not what you say
if if what you say and how you act are
different the only thing people look at
is how you act so all the stuff up on
the wall
if you don't embody it it's useless so I
think of culture as this is a simplistic
way of thinking about it but it's
missing some elements but it's not too
bad it's how how people talk to each
other and how people talk about each
other so how do we treat each other when
we're face to face and how do we talk
about each other when the person is not
present so obviously respect is embedded
in that statement but we also have we
need to have a culture of productivity
and collegiality and cooperation we need
to one of my favorite phrases is you
shine by making others look good so
there's no sharp elbows here there's no
self-promotion that's not working in our
company also it may I just as an aside I
want to say something the stuff I'm
saying now I'd I want to want to be sure
that you you don't think I feel this is
necessary to have a successful company
the world is filled with sharp edged
sharp elbows tough companies that have
been wildly successful so this is not
necessary
this is simply this puts the wind at
your back in my opinion it's more fun to
run a company it's easier to attract and
keep good people it's more self
rewarding at the end of the process
because you've helped people develop
their character David Shaw the football
coach who spoke to us earlier says one
thing that I would add a slight modifier
to we said the culture is set by the
people you bring in I think that's only
true to a degree I think people are not
fully formed and culture always when
they come to your company and they're
influenceable at the margin so if they
see other people being nice to them and
helping them with their work and being
solicitous and taking an interest in
them and working really hard and those
kinds of things they can be influenced
in that direction and that's really your
job as the CEO and if you have that kind
of culture it's really hard for other
companies to steal your good people away
that kind of people you the best
employees the 8a players sure you'll
lose some I mean our company lost a
bunch of them a lot of them went on to
head up their own companies other ones
went on to do other things but our
turnover rate was pretty darn low by the
time we got this figured out which took
a number of years but this stuff really
does work and it makes it much more fun
to go to work I mean can't we hit make
it an enjoyable experience to go to work
it doesn't have to be drudgery can it be
fun can't we like the people and can we
have a community of interest with them
and work hard together and celebrate
their victories and really it's not that
hard to do it just takes a little
attention it does take some
reinforcement and you can call it
policing if you want because when people
drift it's important to pick up on it
and mention it to them nicely and be
sure that they get straightened out and
if the apology is necessary then suggest
that they offer an apology but it isn't
impossible to do and it's very rewarding
great in that in the interest of time
I'm gonna skip ahead and ask one more
question that I know
Irv has some specific thoughts on them
we'll open it up for a little bit of Q&A
and this question is really directed so
there's there are a lot of investors and
board members in the audience here
search for board members and so the
question is what advice do you have for
search fund directors for how to best
work with young CEOs so I'd like to tell
you a story for years I've seen this
term Occam's razor how many of you have
ever seen that term Occam's razor I
never I never know what Occam's razor
was until a few months ago and I decided
I'd look it up and figure it out well
Sir William of Occam which was it's now
spelled OCC a.m. but it was Ock H a.m.
Sir William of Ockham lived in the late
1200s and early 1300s in the town of
Ockham county of Surrey England and he
was what was then called a logician a
logician is a term we don't use anymore
it was a forerunner of the term
philosopher so he was a philosopher and
he and his philosopher friends used to
argue about the principles of existence
and the meaning of life and love and all
this kind of stuff and he came he
developed Occam's razor and Occam's
razor in essence says when there's a
complex problem the simplest answer is
usually the best one and that's where
the razor part came from because he kept
cutting away at assumptions that other
people would make because those
assumptions were shaky and he would end
up with the simplest answer so Occam's
razor has come to apply to other areas
of inquiry as well so my point of view
for your consideration is that Occam's
razor
does not apply
when we're talking about a director
giving advice to a CEO and here's why
suppose a CEO comes to you as a director
and you're 20 years older and you've got
some years of experience and the CEO is
feeling confident enough to ask you hey
what do you think about this what do you
think I should do
well what dynamic is set up with that
question the dynamic that set up is a
junior person who's the CEO is coming to
a more senior person that director and
saying what do you think I should do and
that suggests or that prize likely to
prompt an answer whether the senior
person really knows or has the direct
experience or not so the simplest thing
would be an answer the best answer in
that that context in my opinion is I
don't know let's figure it out same
answer as you heard before I'm not sure
I have some thoughts maybe or I've seen
something like this before but I'm not
sure my context exactly the same as
yours how long do you have to make this
decision and that time be extended isn't
if necessary
what are the alternatives that you see
what are the alternative courses of
action that you see here what are they
and can we develop any other ones that
are less obvious
are there any experts we can turn to
there are often people who have seen
this tens and tens of times I was just
an aboard meeting yesterday where we
were talking about a very specific
intellectual property theft issue and
there are people all over this valley
who know that stuff backwards and
forwards so let's find one of them so
the Socratic method of giving advice is
one that I favor it's a discovery
process it produces more alternatives it
produces more granular and careful
thinking I'm a believer that
instinct or intuition is a wonderful
sixth sense but a very poor first sense
a very poor first sense you know we're
all smart people we've got the intellect
to develop alternatives and to examine
them and refine them and get some expert
advice why don't we do that first and
then maybe let our intuition work on the
new body of data that we've assembled so
I think that's the way to give advice
unless you're absolutely dead sure that
you know why why why forego the
opportunity to go through a careful
discovery process some of these critical
decisions that you can help as a
director CEOs make our inflection points
in that company's history and can really
turn the tide one way or the other in
the success of that business thank you
[Applause]
[Music]